is belief in god slowly disappearing
from our world do you think and
what kind of impact does that have on
society
you wrote
that religion is not our enemy before
the western faiths captured the heart of
our world there was cruelty carnage and
destruction in the 20th century when
religion ceased to be a force of
international politics the scale of
human slaughter was far beyond anything
human beings have ever known what is the
world like when we take religion out of
it i mean i think nietzsche was largely
right you know
it wasn't a statement about god it was a
statement about god's presence in the
world um
and i think that that's largely true
that god is not a force
in
a lot of western society and i believe
that if the force of nihilism
has no
clear counter
without an idea that we're all here for
a purpose
and that our lives are inherently
meaningful
and that there's a god who wishes us to
be better
so
i worry a lot about it and i don't think
i think that the sort of optimism that
things are just going to get better and
better
is
what one philosopher called cut flower
ethics that is we're still living off
the morals that religion gave us but now
that they're separate from the soil that
gave birth to them
i see them wilting so this kind of
optimism for the future of human
civilization you think is in part
grounded in
in a religious society i really do
believe that i mean it was religion that
the greeks looked back at the golden age
of the past
it was the jews who said no the golden
age is in the future right it's the
messiah and i think that that idea that
we're moving towards something better
which i really believe
humanity can do and and absent
destroying ourselves will do you know i
i mean i'm
i'm very excited about the technology
that i won't live to see i think it's
fantastic and that excitement is a kind
of religious excitement because there's
a reason to preserve this whole thing
absolutely because i really think
um
i know this sounds this sounds absurdly
anthropomorphic but i really think god
is cheering us on um i feel like this is
why we're here we're here
to grow in soul and to grow each other
in seoul
yeah
so what do you think the world so if we
just think of this force of nihilism
that's contending with the
force
of faith-based optimism
right
um
what do you make of the atrocities in
the in the 20th century do you think
at its core it's part of human nature
and has nothing to do with religion or
not religion or do you think you can
assign this kind of nihilistic view of
the way i think it has to do with a
religion that doesn't make ethical
demands
that is
um
for stalin and for hitler they both had
religions but they were in a sense but
they were religions that didn't make
ethical demands
for the other i mean 36 times the torah
talks about the stranger
the point is it's trying to educate
people
away from their natural inclination
towards distrusting and disliking the
other and it's a lot of work that's
really difficult to do but if you have
the
the if you have
a tribal passion and not a universal
ethic then you're in trouble
you